Katrina:  然后我们有那种大音箱不
Katrina: Do we have those big speakers?
Shure:  这个可以有
Shure: We can have that.
Katrina:  如果在外面玩的话放点音乐啥
Katrina: If we're playing outside, we can play some music.
Jake: 嗯就放刚刚那个曲子
Katrina: Yeah, just play that song from earlier.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Alice: 嗯大东北
Alice: Umm, Northeast style.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina:  知识问答自我介绍
Katrina: Q&A and self-introduction.
Jake: 打死我吧
Jake: Kill me now.
Jake: 这个花瓶
Jake: This vase.
Katrina:  这是真的酒还是假酒
Katrina: Is this real wine or fake wine?
Jake: 假酒
Jake: Fake wine.
Katrina: 啊我还以为你们已经喝了
Katrina: Ah, I thought you guys already drank it.
Jake: 这是我的水瓶
Jake: This is my water bottle.
Jake: 没有啥毛病哦
Jake: No problem at all.
Katrina:  再拿起出来干一口
Katrina: Pick it up and take a sip.
Jake: 那花瓶拿走了还倒
Jake: The vase was taken away and still spilled.
Katrina:  这多的话等会就放
Katrina: If there’s more, just put it down for now.
Katrina:  这花瓶好
Katrina: This vase is nice.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Alice: 叮零咣当的
Alice: Clang clang.
Shure:  这是个保温杯
Shure: It's a thermos.
Lucia: 啊这居然是保温杯
Lucia: It's actually a thermos.
Shure:  一听就是304不锈钢
Shure: You can tell it's 304 stainless steel.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 厉害了
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 很懂啊大东北
Jake: You really understand, the Northeast.
Jake: 衬衫的是吧
Jake: The one in the shirt, right?
Jake: 东北钢铁厂
Jake: The Northeast steel plant.
Shure:  安钢
Shure: Ansteel.
Shure:  这字写的太好看了
Shure: Your handwriting is beautiful.
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  可歌可泣
Shure: So moving.
Jake: 一看就是中文
Jake: It looks like Chinese.
Shure:  哦我们还要写个英文版吗
Shure: Oh, do we need to write an English version too?
Jake:: 不用不用不用
Jake: 哎呦对
Jake: Oh yeah, right.
Jake: 我们字写的好
Jake: Our writing is good.
Shure: : 我们应该international一点
Shure:  你看我那个英文就明显跟这个
Shure: Look, my English is obviously...
Jake: 那好下面开始写英文吧
Jake: Okay, let's start writing in English then.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:时间线
Jake: Timeline.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 来咱俩换一下
Shure: Let's switch places.
Shure:  你去那边坐一会去
Shure: You go sit over there for a bit.
Jake: 或坐这
Jake: Or sit here.
Shure:  timeline为啥是俩词
Shure: Why is "timeline" two words?
Alice: 时间线吧
Alice: It's timeline.
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Shure:  这个
Shure: This...
Jake: 也行
Jake:   it works.
Jake:也行也行
Jake: It works, it works.
Shure:  强调一下这个life
Shure: Emphasize this "life".
Jake:好好
Jake: Good, good.
Shure: 线
Shure: Line.
Shure:  首先我们几点入场
Shure: First, what time do we enter?
Jake: 3点 3点吧
Jake: 3 o'clock, 3 o'clock.
Jake: 应该是2点到3点逐步入场
Jake: They should start entering around 2 to 3 PM.
Jake: 然后前面可能签到的人
Jake: And then maybe the people who signed in earlier can walk around.
Katrina: 逛逛
Katrina: Walk around.
Jake: 对给他们一点活动
Jake: Yeah, give them some activities.
Shure:  鹌鹑
Shure: Quail.
Jake:哈哈神经
Jake: Haha, silly.
Shure:  入场是怎么拍的吗
Shure: How do we film the entrance?
Katrina:  2点半到3点
Katrina: From 2:30 to 3 PM.
Shure:  okay对
Shure: Okay, right.
Jake: 这意思就是3点之前
Jake: So that means before 3 PM.
Jake: 我们搞一些flexible的游戏或者活动
Jake: We can do some flexible games or activities.
Jake: 然后3点准时干点什么东西
Jake: And then at 3 PM, we do something.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  game
Shure: Game.
Shure:  before
Shure: Before.
Shure:  是不是污染数据
Shure: Will it contaminate the data?
Jake: 不污染
Shure: Definitely not.
Jake: 这是人类的正常行为
Jake: This is normal human behavior.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: ok第二点还有什么
Shure: Okay, what else is there for the second point?
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else then?
Jake: 然后3点干啥了
Jake: What to do at 3 PM?
Jake: 3点开始就有知识问答和自我介绍
Jake: Starting at 3 PM, we have a Q&A session and self-introductions.
Shure:  那这这些呢
Shure: So, what about these?
Katrina:  这些就是我们要让他们先获得货币
Katrina: For these, we need to let them earn some currency first.
Katrina:  以后我们再推销我们自己的产品
Katrina: Then we can promote our products.
Katrina:  我其实感觉不确定
Katrina: Actually, I feel uncertain.
Katrina:  他们到底是E人还是I人
Katrina: Are they E-type or I-type people?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就万一
Katrina: Just in case.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina:  其实可能不会持续很长的时间
Katrina: Actually, it might not last very long.
Katrina:  自我介绍
Katrina: Self-introduction.
Katrina: 知识问答40分钟吧
Katrina: We've been asking for 40 minutes, right?
Katrina:  加自我介绍
Katrina: Plus self-introduction.
Shure:  您说
Shure: You can say
Jake: 也行抢答对吧
Jake: It too. quick response, right?
Katrina:  嗯很快其实
Katrina: Yeah, it's actually pretty quick.
Jake: 对对挺好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's good.
Shure:  and知识问答
Shure: And knowledge quiz.
Katrina: QA
Katrina: QA.
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Wonderful.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  第3点
Shure: The third point.
Katrina:  然后就每个人介绍自己做的这个
Katrina: Then each person introduces what they've done.
Katrina:  然后就跟他们说
Katrina: Then just tell them.
Katrina:  他们可以拿他们的货币来
Katrina: They can use their currency to...
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:大家插会电吧
Jake: Let's all plug in for a bit.
Jake: 你们继续聊
Jake: Okay, you guys keep chatting.
Jake: 我给大家发线
Jake: I'll hand out the cables.
Katrina:  40个
Katrina: 40.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: Okay, then?
Jake: 哦你一直插着的
Jake: Oh, you kept it plugged in?
Shure:  我一直插着充电宝
Shure: I kept it plugged in with a power bank.
Jake: 给我
Jake: Give it to me.
Jake: 这个是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我我的
Katrina: Mine.
Jake: 好那你插上吧少一个
Jake: Okay, then plug it in, one less.
Lucia: 我也插上了
Lucia: I've plugged mine in too.
Shure:  3
Katrina: 介绍自己的产品吗
Katrina: Are we introducing our products?
Katrina:  每个人啊
Katrina: Each of us?
Shure:  3就开始拍卖
Shure: Then we start the auction.
Shure:  怎么说
Shure: How should we say it?
Lucia: auction
Lucia: Auction.
Shure:  auction啊AUC
Shure: Auction, AUC.
Jake: 你也插一个吧
Jake: You should plug one in too.
Shure: auction
Shure: Auction.
Alice: 哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thank you.
Shure:  预计3:40到
Shure: Estimated arrival at 3:40.
Lucia: 一个小时
Lucia: One hour.
Lucia: 或许4点半吧差不多
Lucia: Maybe around 4:30.
Katrina:  你这拍卖
Katrina: This auction...
Katrina:  指的是拍卖他们自己带带的东西
Katrina: Are we auctioning the things they brought?
Katrina:  还是谁来拍卖
Katrina: Or who's auctioning?
Shure:  自己的和
Shure: Both ours and theirs.
Katrina: 他们自己带的
Katrina: The things they brought.
Katrina:  对和我们的
Katrina: Yes, and ours.
Lucia: 和咱们的产品
Lucia: And our products.
Katrina:  那应该不止一个小时吧
Katrina: It should take more than an hour then.
Lucia: 不止吗那就再长一个半小时
Lucia: More than an hour? Then maybe an hour and a half.
Katrina:  一个半小时差不多
Katrina: About an hour and a half.
Shure: 我们可以细分
Shure: We can segment it.
Shure:  这个是他们自己的部分
Shure: This is their part.
Shure:  这是guest part
Shure: This is the guest part.
Lucia: 这些这些
Lucia: These, these.
Katrina:  这些gets
Katrina: These items.
Katrina:  他们带多少东西
Katrina: How much stuff did they bring?
Lucia: 以及他们是I人还是E人
Lucia: And are they I-types or E-types?
Katrina:  对这就不确定
Katrina: Right, that's uncertain.
Shure:  呃然后还有什么我们的
Shure: Uh, what else do we have?
Shure:  或者我们可以提前来
Shure: Or we can come earlier.
Shure:  活跃一下这个气氛
Shure: Let's liven up the atmosphere.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  我觉得我们先开始吧
Katrina: I think we should start first.
Shure:  我们先开始
Shure: Let's start first.
Katrina:  3:40到4点半
Katrina: From 3:40 to 4:30.
Katrina:  是我们先开始
Katrina: We'll start first.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We will.
Shure: 会会这么
Shure: About 8 minutes.
Katrina: 七八分钟差不多
Katrina: Seven or eight minutes, roughly.
Katrina:  七八分钟
Katrina: Seven or eight minutes.
Katrina:  那40分钟差不多
Katrina: So, about 40 minutes in total.
Katrina:  那就4:20
Katrina: So, at 4:20.
Shure: 4:20吧
Shure: 4:20 then.
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or...
Lucia: 直接把他们把这段变成我们整体的
Lucia: We could just turn this part into our overall...
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: A...
Lucia: 形容一个小续集也行
Lucia: Think of it as a small sequel.
Lucia: 就是可以让他们先
Lucia: We could let them go first.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 就是如果对咱们整体的这个手工制品
Lucia: Yeah, if they enjoy our handmade products overall.
Lucia: 感觉就好比我们是一个商家一样
Lucia: Just like we're a merchant.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 然后如果大家玩的比较高兴的
Lucia: Then they can trade among themselves later.
Lucia: 话就后面让他们在自己之间交换
Lucia: They can trade among themselves later.
Katrina:  都行也可以
Katrina: That works too.
Alice:反正现在我们买了花瓶嘛
Alice: Anyway, we bought vases, right?
Katrina:  对对对我买6个
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, I bought six.
Alice: 还有在哪呢
Alice: Where are they?
Katrina:  人家都到了
Katrina: They're all here.
Katrina:  但是这花可以让他们自己插
Katrina: But they can arrange the flowers themselves.
Alice: 就是现在不是醒花吗
Alice: Aren't the flowers blooming now?
Alice: 嗯就是
Alice: Yeah, so...
Katrina:  我的意思是
Katrina: What I mean is...
Katrina:  可以大家自己搭配自己挑嘛
Katrina: Everyone can mix and choose by themselves.
Alice: 哦你的意思是
Alice: Oh, you mean...
Katrina: 六六个瓶子吗
Katrina: Six bottles, right?
Katrina:  然后多的就放这种公共的
Katrina: And the extras can be placed in the communal area.
Katrina:  刚才还有花瓶啥的
Katrina: There were vases and stuff just now.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Alice:先醒醒他吧
Alice: Let's wake him up first.
Jake: 我们的食品环节吃饭环下午茶环节
Jake: Our food session, eating session, afternoon tea session.
Jake: 在什么地方
Jake: Where are they?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  啊要有一直有一个酒保在那边
Shure: Ah, there should always be a bartender over there.
Shure:  哈哈哈一直有一个酒保
Shure: Hahaha, always a bartender.
Jake: 那酒保在什么位置呢
Jake: Where would the bartender be located?
Katrina:  我感觉就外面这里已经很好了
Katrina: I think outside here is already pretty good.
Jake: 那调酒是在外面
Jake: So the mixing is outside.
Katrina:  但是但是但是我喝酒
Katrina: But, but, but I drink...
Lucia: 调酒是在这个台子上跳
Lucia: The mixing is done on this counter.
Jake: 也可以啊在室内然后如果有人
Jake: That works, inside, and if anyone...
Shure: 就在这
Shure: Just right here.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina:  对刚才那表演就是待在外面的
Katrina: Yeah, the performance just now was outside.
Lucia: 玻璃就可以看到
Lucia: You can see through the glass.
Lucia: 调酒师在里面
Lucia: The bartender is inside.
Lucia: 如何哇好高级啊
Lucia: How? Wow, so fancy.
Jake:对是是
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Lucia: 来来一点打光
Lucia: Let's add some lighting.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 对我们还有这个影棚灯
Lucia: Yeah, we also have this studio light.
Lucia: 虽然这个我们是就一个
Lucia: Though we only have one.
Lucia: 一个灯吗
Lucia: One light?
Jake: 我们四个啊
Jake: No, four of them.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake:现在还没装晚一会装一下
Jake: We haven't set it up yet, we'll do it in a bit.
Katrina:  那那下午茶时间要不要弄到4:20之后
Katrina: Should we move the afternoon tea time to after 4:20?
Katrina:  要不然插在哪个地方
Katrina: Otherwise, where should we fit it in?
Lucia: 就我觉得4:20之后就可以
Lucia: Yeah, I think anytime after 4:20 works.
Shure: 可以大家边吃边干嘛
Shure: We can eat while doing other things.
Lucia: 因为一般来说
Lucia: Because usually,
Lucia: 下午茶就是3点到5点这个时间段
Lucia: Afternoon tea is typically between 3 and 5 PM.
Jake: 就可能我们一一部分人
Jake: Maybe some of us can...
Jake: 还是我们先做好
Jake: How about we prepare first?
Jake: 我们可以先做好吗
Jake: Can we prepare first?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:就是那些
Jake: The desserts.
Jake:甜品
Jake: Desserts.
Katrina: 甜品
Katrina: Desserts?
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Katrina:  哎那就是反正他他他的是种子片
Katrina: Well, his part is the final touch.
Katrina:  就加甜品
Katrina: Add the desserts.
Katrina:  就在3:40-4:20介绍
Katrina: Introduce them between 3:40 and 4:20.
Katrina:  然后他作为我们几个的压轴
Katrina: He'll be our grand finale.
Katrina:  然后介绍完了以后大家可以分发一下
Katrina: After the introduction, we can distribute them.
Jake: 买甜品是吧
Katrina:  尝一下他的那个甜品
Katrina: Everyone can try his desserts.
Katrina:  对他们是摆台
Katrina: They'll be displayed.
Katrina:  也有钱了嘛
Katrina: It's a nice setup, right?
Tasha: 甜品摆台吗
Alice: A setup?
Alice:摆台吗
Katrina: A setup?
Jake: 摆什么
Jake: What's being set up?
Tasha: 甜品摆台
Tasha: Dessert display.
Lucia: 就是 下午茶
Lucia: It's for afternoon tea.
Alice:下午成塔的
Alice: For the afternoon.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Seriously?
Alice: 看一下就觉得好看
Alice: Yeah, it'll look great, of course we can.
Jake: 当然可以摆
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 那就是甜品台做一次要800-1,000呢
Tasha: So, setting up a dessert table costs around 800-1,000.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Shure:  怎么杨老板突然空手了
Shure: Why is Jake suddenly empty-handed?
Shure:  应该是哈哈哈
Shure: Maybe it's hahaha
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Tasha: 没有只是买个甜品台架子
Tasha: No, just buying the dessert table stand.
Jake: 架子1,000是吧
Jake: The stand is 1,000, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:那是什么
Jake: Then what is it?
Lucia: 总共的吧
Lucia: It's the total, right?
Lucia: 总共500-1,000
Jake: The total is 500-1,000.
Tasha: 就是你你去做的话
Tasha: That's if you make it yourself.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 去外面吗
Shure: For outside?
Katrina:  哎但是你需不需要很多机器啊
Katrina: But don't you need a lot of machines?
Tasha: 嗯基础的买了
Tasha: Hmm, just bought the basic ones.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯除湿机什么的肯定没买
Tasha: Hmm, definitely didn't buy a dehumidifier or anything.
Jake: 能能多少钱
Jake: How much would that cost?
Tasha:  嗯不能买
Tasha: Hmm, can't buy it.
Jake: 呵呵呵不能买是什么
Tasha: Haha, what do you mean can't buy?
Jake: 太贵了
Jake: Too expensive, right?
Tasha: 嗯对啊呵呵
Tasha: Haha, thousands of dollars.
Jake:上万
Tasha: 嗯几千块钱吧
Tasha: Hmm, a few thousand.
Jake: OK嗯可以
Jake: OK, that's fine.
Tasha: 甜品台就类似这样子哦
Tasha: The dessert table is like this.
Jake: 哦
Katrina:  啊看一眼好漂亮啊
Katrina: Ah, it looks so beautiful!
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 差不多是我设想的那个大盘子好漂亮
Lucia: It's pretty much what I imagined, so beautiful.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 到时候坐在这里
Tasha: We'll sit here then.
Lucia: 可以每次开学术会议的时候就是这样
Lucia: We can set it up like this every time we have an academic meeting.
Tasha: 就想去吃哈哈哈
Tasha: Just want to eat, hahaha.
Katrina:  学术蝗虫
Katrina: Evil locusts.
Tasha: 是这样的
Tasha: Exactly.
Jake:可以
Tasha: 这样子的
Lucia: 而且关键是老师一般都不怎么吃
Lucia: And the key thing is the teacher usually doesn't eat much.
Lucia: 结果都是我吃
Lucia: So I end up eating it all.
Jake: 还打包打了一包回去
Jake: And you even packed some to take home.
Jake: 烧烤吗
Jake: Barbecue?
Katrina:  烧烤偏晚上吧
Katrina: Barbecue is usually for the evening.
Jake: 晚上再吃
Jake: Let's eat it at night then.
Katrina:  那就是但是你要留他们到晚上的话
Katrina: But if you want to keep them until the evening...
Katrina:  这个晚饭怎么弄
Katrina: What about dinner then?
Jake: 一起烤呗
Jake: Let's all grill together.
Shure:  大家
Shure:  一起吃这个是吗
Shure: Eat together, right?
Jake: 一起吃什么
Katrina:  烧烤的人有点累哦
Katrina:  因为有20个人左右
Katrina: Because there are about 20 people.
Lucia: 如果来的人多的话
Lucia: If a lot of people come...
Lucia: 就是都烧烤还挺麻麻烦的
Lucia: Grilling for everyone would be quite troublesome.
Lucia: 嗯确实而且包饭也麻烦
Lucia: Yeah, and preparing rice is also a hassle.
Shure:  确实
Katrina:  点外卖也麻烦
Katrina: Ordering takeout is also troublesome.
Lucia: 确实
Jake: 确实
Katrina:  点点披萨到还行
Shure:  放进去哎
Katrina: Just put it in, hey.
Lucia: 对就是可能每人吃那么一两块
Lucia: Right, maybe everyone just eats one or two pieces.
Lucia: 也不是说要吃的非常饱嘛
Lucia: It's not like we need to be super full.
Shure:  蘸点披萨
Shure: Dip it in pizza.
Shure:  有那个32寸这么大
Shure: It's like 32 inches big.
Jake: 那个披萨
Jake: That pizza...
Jake: 行可以
Shure: 弄一张就可以
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sounds good.
Katrina:  就到了晚饭的点就摆在这
Katrina: Just have it ready by dinner time.
Jake: 对对
Katrina:  对大家饿了自己吃
Katrina: Yeah, everyone can eat around five.
Jake: 五点吃
Lucia: 而且如果之前有
Lucia: 吃甜的东西的话可能也不会特别的饿
Lucia: If they've had something sweet before, they won't be too hungry.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Exactly.
Jake: 那就5点半的时候
Jake: So at 5:30...
Jake: 一个大披萨差不多
Jake: One big pizza.
Katrina:  嗯现在是5点
Katrina: Yeah, it's 5 now.
Katrina:  嗯 5点
Katrina: Yeah, 5.
Katrina:  那我们的节目就弄到晚上一样
Katrina: Then our program will run until evening.
Katrina:  因为我当时想的是
Katrina: Because what I was thinking...
Katrina:  你那个讲故事的话大家不是很熟
Katrina: If you tell a story, people won't be very familiar with it.
Katrina:  因为你那个讲故事设定在酒吧
Katrina: Because you set the story in a bar.
Katrina:  根据酒吧大家都是有故事的人
Katrina: In a bar, everyone has a story to tell.
Katrina:  可能就在那种环境下
Katrina: Maybe in that kind of environment,
Katrina:  然后就愿意讲
Katrina: they’d be more willing to talk.
Katrina:  但是我们这种刚过来
Katrina: But for people like us who just got here,
Katrina:  他们可能不太愿意讲故事
Katrina: they might not be so willing to share their stories.
Katrina:  所以改成自我介绍还挺好
Katrina: So changing it to self-introductions is good.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina:  如果说要讲故事或获金币这个环节
Katrina: if we want to do a story-telling or coin-earning segment,
Katrina:  我觉得可以弄到偏晚上1点
Katrina: I think we could move it to around 1 AM.
Katrina:  大家已经熟了一点
Katrina: By then, everyone’s more familiar.
Katrina:  再加上晚上比较感性
Katrina: Plus, people are more emotional at night.
Katrina:  可以带着一点自己的故事过来
Katrina: They might bring their personal stories.
Katrina:  然后那
Katrina: And then,
Katrina:  那就5点
Katrina: so at 5 PM,
Katrina:  是他们介绍完他们的pass
Katrina: after they introduce themselves,
Katrina:  然后5点到6点就吃烧烤调酒这种吗
Katrina: from 5 to 6 PM, we could have BBQ and cocktails, right?
Jake: 可以啊
Katrina:  其实他并不会完全严格的按照这个
Katrina: Actually, it won’t be strictly according to this schedule.
Jake: 对
Katrina: 所以可以搞个5点到6点的区间
Shure:  反正开饭dinner
Shure: Anyway, dinner starts
Shure:  在5点半之后
Shure: after 5:30 PM.
Shure:  5点半左右
Shure: Around 5:30, yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Jake: 大披萨
Jake: a bow
Jake: A bow.
Jake: 第一个披萨
Jake: The first pizza.
Katrina:  第一个披萨还有BBQ
Katrina: The first pizza and BBQ.
Shure:  bbq
Shure: BBQ.
Katrina:  那调酒的话是属于贯穿始终
Katrina: As for cocktails, they’ll be available throughout.
Shure:  对就像甜品和
Shure: Yeah, like desserts and
Katrina:  他们入场的时候
Shure:  是ers ert吧
Shure:  嗯还是SS
Shure: Yeah, or SS.
Jake: : 什么SS
Shure: WS乘2
Katrina:  哦你说甜品啊
Katrina: Oh, you mean desserts?
Shure:  and
Shure: And
Katrina:  那晚上就还剩啥
Katrina: So, what’s left for the evening?
Katrina:  我想想还剩我们的节目
Katrina: Let me think. Our program.
Jake: 对我们有
Jake: Yeah, we have
Katrina:  然后也不能弄太晚
Katrina: And it shouldn’t be too late.
Katrina:  他们回去的话要两个小时
Katrina: If they go back, it'll take two hours.
Jake: 嗯那我们就定个结束时间
Jake: Hmm, then let's set an end time.
Katrina: 8点
Jake: 可以
Shure: 贯彻失重
Jake:  can accommodate weightlessness.
Katrina:  2点半到8点差不多了
Katrina: From 2:30 to 8 o'clock, that should be enough.
Katrina:  忙够呛了
Katrina: It's going to be quite busy, right?
Jake:对
Katrina:  跟戴娜差不多
Katrina: About the same as Dana.
Katrina:  到6点半
Katrina: Until 6:30.
Katrina:  然后还有一个半小时就是表演
Katrina: Then there's another hour and a half for the performance.
Katrina:  表演节目
Katrina: The performance show.
Katrina:  能让他们也准备点节目吗
Katrina: Can we have them prepare some acts too?
Katrina:  有没有那种擅长唱歌的
Katrina: Is there anyone good at singing?
Shure:  可以反正我们又把吉他
Shure: Sure, we also brought a guitar anyway.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Hmm, right.
Katrina:  啊唱唱歌跳跳舞
Katrina: Ah, sing and dance.
Jake: 对时间太长了
Jake: Yeah, that's too long.
Lucia: 来一个大家一起卡拉OK的环节吧
Lucia: Let's have a karaoke session together.
Jake:啊也可以
Katrina:  哪个时间太长
Katrina: Which part is too long?
Jake: 不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我我我是说中间可能有一个小时
Jake: I mean, there's probably an hour in between.
Jake: 我们要传数据
Jake: We need to transfer data.
Jake: 你们的眼镜
Jake: Your eyes.
Katrina:  传数据让他们自己逛逛我们的世界
Katrina: Let's let them explore our world on their own.
Katrina:  然后喝点酒
Katrina: And have a drink.
Lucia: 传数据的时候带大家唱唱歌好了
Lucia: While transferring data, we can have everyone sing.
Shure:  free time
Alice:在这放一个小电影或者干嘛的
Shure: During free time, we can play a short film or something.
Shure:  小电影对对对
Shure: Short film, right, right.
Jake: 中间中间空一个小时差大概
Jake: We'll leave an hour gap in between, roughly.
Shure:  对当时还说那个
Shure: 就3点什么时候
Jake: 6点纪录片什么的
Jake: At 6 o'clock, there'll be a documentary or something.
Katrina:  那就是那个5点结束之后呗
Katrina: So, that's after it ends at 5 o'clock, right?
Jake: 对啊他家吃披萨时候咱就不拍了吧
Jake: Yeah, when they eat pizza at home, we won't film, right?
Jake: 行
Tasha:甜品是什么
Tasha: 也可以哪个时间段吃甜品
Tasha: We can have dessert at any time.
Jake: 甜品是
Katrina:  甜品是你就是我
Katrina: Dessert is you and me.
Shure:  贯彻始终
Katrina:  host host part
Tasha:啊
Katrina: 就是他们一二环节
Katrina:  不是会得金币吗
Katrina: Don't they earn coins?
Katrina:  然后3:40到4:20的时候
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20,
Katrina:  我们介绍我们的产品
Katrina: We'll introduce our products.
Katrina:  然后我想的是你放在最后
Katrina: And I was thinking of putting you at the end.
Katrina:  然后就是刚好这个part结束了
Katrina: Then, just as this part ends.
Katrina:  以后大家就可以尝你的甜品
Katrina: Everyone will get to taste your desserts in the future.
Tasha: 4:20
Tasha: 4:20,
Katrina:  对就是你压轴
Katrina: right.You're the finale.
Katrina:  哈哈你介绍你的种子片和你的甜品
Katrina: Haha, you introduce your seed films and your desserts.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们自己做的种
Katrina: We'll introduce the seeds we made ourselves.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure, yeah.
Jake: 嗯3点到5点两个小时够
Jake: Two hours from 3 to 5 should be enough.
Tasha: 大概从早上就要开始准备
Tasha: We'll probably need to start preparing in the morning.
Tasha: 然后需要配两个人
Tasha: And we need two people.
Lucia: 可以我可以帮忙
Lucia: I can help.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就想写
Katrina: Hahaha, just want to write.
Tasha: 哈哈哈配两个人
Shure: 真的起得来吗
Katrina:  可以的我今天只是失误
Katrina: Yes, I just made a mistake today.
Katrina:  哈哈哈到时候死都没想到
Katrina: Hahaha, you'll never expect it when the time comes.
Shure:  我听到了你的闹钟
Shure: I heard your alarm clock.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  不是你怎么听到
Katrina: How did you hear it?
Katrina:  你不是住一楼吗
Katrina: Don't you live on the first floor?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  因为咱俩应该就是差不多上上下这种
Shure: Because we're almost right above and below each other.
Shure:  啊你那个跟我是一样的
Shure: Ah, your alarm is the same as mine.
Lucia: 不过也正常
Lucia: But that's normal.
Lucia: 我我我本科舍友回我早晨定的闹铃
Lucia: My undergrad roommate would wake up to my alarm in the morning.
Lucia: 我舍友都醒了
Lucia: My roommate would be awake.
Lucia: 我自己还没醒
Shure: 自己就听不见.
Katrina:  嗯明天定三个
Katrina: Hmm, set three alarms tomorrow.
Katrina:  那就差不多想想啊
Katrina: That should be about right.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 所以那一天的甜品是要当天做
Jake: So, do we make the desserts on the same day?
Jake: 还是可以前一天做
Jake: Or can we make them the day before?
Tasha: 有的需要冷藏的会前一天做
Tasha: Some that need refrigeration will be made the day before.
Tasha: 比如提拉米苏
Tasha: Like tiramisu.
Katrina:  哎其实像那种
Katrina: Oh, actually for those...
Katrina:  就是我看他们那种清补凉那种
Katrina: Like I see them making those chilled desserts.
Katrina:  是不是就买点椰奶然后做点圆
Katrina: Can we just buy some coconut milk and make some balls?
Tasha: 清补凉的话那是不是好调一点啊
Tasha: Chilled desserts are a bit easier to prepare, right?
Tasha: 也是前一天做好
Tasha: Also made the day before.
Tasha: 然后第二天就直接把原料
Tasha: Then the next day we just put the ingredients together.
Tasha: 然后进行一个配就行
Tasha: Just need to mix them, right?
Tasha: 对对对就是用那个吉利丁片和椰奶
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, just use gelatin sheets and coconut milk.
Tasha: 就可以做
Tasha: You can just make it.
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: It seems like...
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们有的那种糖水就是直接椰奶
Katrina: I've seen some of those sweet soups, they just use coconut milk.
Katrina:  然后加一点水果
Katrina: And then add a bit of fruit.
Katrina:  加一点芋圆就行了
Katrina: Add some taro balls, and that's it.
Tasha: 哦
Katrina:  感觉那样会不会简单一点
Katrina: Do you think that would be simpler?
Katrina:  就不要做成那种冻不起的那种
Katrina: So we don't make it into that kind that doesn't solidify.
Katrina:  就不要用那个什么吉利饮片
Katrina: Just don't use that gelatin stuff.
Tasha: 那清不了好吃吗
Tasha: Will it taste good if it's not clear?
Tasha: 你觉得
Katrina: 我觉得随便
Katrina:  就是我感觉会不会简单一点那种吗
Katrina: I just think that would be simpler, right?
Tasha: 他说不要液体不要固体的啊
Tasha: He said no liquid, no solid, right?
Katrina:  就是直接就像那种水牛奶一样的
Katrina: Just make it like that milk-water thing.
Katrina:  因为我自己经常喝的糖水
Katrina: Because the sweet soup I drink often...
Katrina:  我看他们就是一点椰奶啊
Katrina: They just use a bit of coconut milk.
Katrina:  然后芒果然后一些那个红豆
Katrina: Then mango, and some red beans.
Katrina:  就就这样配就很快
Katrina: Just mix it like that, and it's done quickly.
Katrina:  嗯就是芋圆可能要熬一下
Katrina: Hmm, the taro balls might need to be cooked a bit.
Katrina:  椰果呢都能现买耶
Katrina: Coconut jelly can be bought ready-made.
Katrina:  随便看你看你吧
Katrina: It's up to you, whatever you think.
Katrina:  你说什么就是什么
Katrina: Whatever you say goes.
Alice: 你准备了芋圆的东西吗
Alice: Did you prepare taro balls?
Tasha: 芋圆我
Tasha: Taro balls, I...
Tasha: 我没有买芋圆材料
Tasha: I didn't buy any ingredients for taro balls.
Katrina:  芋圆是不是可以直接买
Katrina: Can't we just buy taro balls?
Katrina:  芋圆也有成品吧
Katrina: They have ready-made ones, right?
Tasha: 嗯对
Katrina: 直接买成品
Katrina:  那我看看
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina:  4:20介绍完以后
Katrina: After introducing at 4:20...
Katrina:  要有一个品尝甜品的时间
Katrina: There should be a dessert tasting time.
Katrina:  那是不是要到4点
Katrina: So that should be at 4:00?
Katrina:  4:35开始
Katrina: Start at 4:35.
Katrina:  但是我到5点多
Katrina: But by 5:00...
Katrina:  然后就开始吃晚饭晚饭
Katrina: We should start eating dinner.
Katrina:  就是gas part之后我们就收眼镜传数据
Katrina: So after the gas part, we'll pack up the glasses and transfer the data.
Jake: 对对对
Katrina: 然后吃饭就不录
Jake: 吃饭不录
Jake: No recording during dinner.
Tasha: 那那晚饭是自己做吗
Tahsa : So, are we making dinner ourselves?
Jake:晚饭大披萨
Katrina:  晚饭就那个点披萨嘛
Katrina: Dinner, we'll just get pizza around that time.
Tasha: 哦点个披萨不好意思
Katrina:  然后一些烧烤
Katrina: And then some barbecue.
Jake: 烧烤也不能录烧烤把
Jake: We can't record the barbecue too, can we?
Jake: 把眼镜给烧坏了
Jake: Put the glasses away.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Katrina:  没事刚好那那一个小时
Katrina: It's okay, just for that one hour.
Katrina:  那你就传数据
Shure: 定一个披萨得了
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, barbecue.
Shure:  barbecue再说
Shure: Let's talk about it later.
Jake:五点到
Shure:  可以咱们咱们这两天自个吃
Shure: We can have barbecue ourselves in the next couple of days.
Jake: 哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what is that?
Jake: 芭比q自己试试
Jake: Try the BBQ yourself.
Alice: 那个是烧烤炉吗
Alice: Is that a barbecue grill?
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, it is.
Alice: 哦还挺大
Jake: Oh, it's quite big.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  然后人太多的话
Shure: If there are too many people,
Shure:  芭比q真的不好不好玩
Shure: BBQ isn't that fun.
Alice: 特别慢对
Alice: It's really slow, yeah.
Jake: 那就不要芭比q
Jake: Then let's not do BBQ.
Jake: 没关系或者给他整两串得了
Jake: It's fine, or we can just grill a couple of skewers for him.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 意思意思
Jake: Hahaha, just for the gesture.
Jake: 那就是意思
Jake: That's the idea.
Jake: 哈哈哈那是我自己烤的
Jake: Hahaha, I grilled it myself.
Lucia: 点到点进来然后就自己烤的
Lucia: Just bring it over and say you grilled it yourself.
Lucia: 说是烤的
Lucia: Say it's grilled.
Shure:  对菜咱们只买菜然后热一下
Shure: Yeah, we just buy the food and then heat it up.
小薇 : 哇哈哈哈
Jake:好妙啊
Jake: 哈哈挺好看的
Jake: Hahaha, it looks great.
小薇 : 点进来然后
Lucia: 有西餐厅那种圆的那样罩住
Lucia: Like those round covers in Western restaurants.
Lucia: 要不然话
Lucia: Otherwise,
Lucia: 大家就会发现
Lucia: everyone will see
Lucia: 你这个拿出来的时候
Lucia: when you take it out,
Lucia: 就已经是烤好的了
Lucia: that it's already grilled.
Jake:哦
Lucia: 然后就这样挡一下
Lucia: Just cover it up,
Lucia: 然后放在炉上烤一烤
Lucia: then grill it a bit on the stove.
Lucia: 说是刚烤的
Lucia: Say it's freshly grilled.
Jake: 哈哈哈是是是
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  太天才了
Shure: That's genius.
Jake: 我们对一分钟考好
Jake: We can grill it in one minute.
Katrina:  那就我们的那个活动就6点半到8点
Katrina: So our event will be from 6:30 to 8.
Katrina:  节目唱唱歌跳舞
Katrina: Singing and dancing for the show.
Katrina:  一个半小时够了再长弄不下去了
Katrina: An hour and a half is enough, any longer and we can't handle it.
Shure:  free time
Katrina: 对
Shure: 大家可以表演
Katrina:  一个半小时
Shure:  然后我们可以auction拆出来也行
Shure: Then we can auction off stuff too.
Shure:  就是比如说没进行完有的人没拍
Shure: Like if we don't finish, some people didn't bid.
Shure:  拍完然后
Katrina: 啊可以继续想分享
Katrina:  接着大家自由交换
Jake:也行也行
Lucia:嗯反正一般等家务已经有了
Lucia: Hmm, anyway, usually household chores are done.
Katrina: 那就是5点半开饭然后6点半
Katrina: So we start eating at 5:30, and then I have to leave by 6:30.
Tasha: 那如果要走了钱没花完怎么办
Tasha: What if we don't spend all the money?
Jake: 什么什么钱没花完
Jake: What do you mean, not spending the money?
Shure:  就是那个硬币啊
Shure: I mean the coins.
小薇 : 硬币啊
Jake: 硬币在
Shure: 我们要空掉那个通货
Katrina:  我们把我们的送或
Jake: 对对对送俩充电宝吧
Jake: Right, right, let's give away two power banks.
Jake: 要不
Katrina: 送点充电宝
Tasha: 这这挺好的
Tasha: That's good.
Katrina:  还可以这个反正最后一天了
Katrina: Yeah, that's fine since it's the last day anyway.
Shure: : 确实
Katrina:  你是不是也不太
Katrina: Aren't you also...
Jake: 是的是的
Katrina: 抽奖环节
Katrina:  哈哈哈我到时候也可以买一个
Katrina: Hahaha, I might buy one then.
小薇 : 粉丝答谢会
Katrina:  晚会晚会都送充电宝
Katrina: At the party, we'll give away power banks.
Lucia: 我们也是
Lucia: Us too.
Lucia: 我们招聘会也会送充电宝
Lucia: We give away power banks at our job fairs too.
Jake: 哦原因找到了是吧
Jake: Oh, that's the reason, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  可以那就把充电宝送出去
Katrina: Okay, then let's give away the power banks.
Tasha: 只要来就可以送一个充电宝
Tasha: Anyone who comes can get a power bank.
Katrina:  看他们手上有
Katrina: Look, they have it in their hands.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  没有插上
Shure: No MLM.
Shure:  嗯好这回插上
Shure: Hmm, okay, now it's plugged in.
Jake: 哎我摸摸
Jake: Let me feel it.
Jake: 哎呀你这个没电了
Jake: Oh, you're out of battery.
Jake: 已经没了
Jake: It's gone.
Jake: 你这已经断掉了啊
Jake: It's already disconnected.
Shure:  对重新录一下
Shure: Alright, let's re-record this.
Jake: 对你你得
Jake: Yeah, you need to.
Jake: 没关系就是我们重新看一遍时间就行
Jake: It's fine, we just need to recheck the time.
Jake: 因为
Katrina: 我的亮吗
Lucia: 它亮着呢
Lucia: It's lit up.
Jake: 你再重新开一下
Jake: Can you restart it again?
Shure:  素材丢失
Shure: The material is lost.
Jake: 稍有丢失问题不大
Jake: A little loss is not a big deal.
Katrina:  那你你的那part的东西买了吗
Katrina: So, did you buy the stuff for your part?
Lucia: 我们取决于我们要做什么
Lucia: It depends on what we're doing.
Lucia: 我要买水母
Lucia: I need to buy jellyfish.
Lucia: 不是如果要买水母灯
Lucia: No, I mean if we need to buy jellyfish lamps.
Lucia: 如果要做水母灯的话
Lucia: If we are making jellyfish lamps.
Lucia: 大家是想用材料包做还是
Lucia: Do you want to use a material kit or
Lucia: 就是那种循环利用的做
Lucia: make it with recyclable materials?
Katrina:  什么叫循环利用的做
Katrina: What do you mean by recyclable materials?
Lucia: 就是拿那个
Lucia: Like using those...
Lucia: 呃叫什么奶茶盖那种
Lucia: Uh, like, milk tea lids or something.
Lucia: 虽然奶茶盖其实我也没做过
Lucia: Although I've never done it with milk tea lids.
Lucia: 我之前做过材料包
Lucia: I used a material kit before.
Katrina:  奶茶盖的话那是不是得买奶茶呀
Katrina: If we use milk tea lids, we'd need to buy milk tea, right?
Lucia: 确实啊我们可以买个奶茶盖哦
Lucia: Actually, we could just buy a milk tea lid.
Jake: 好没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Lucia: 然后它其实材料还蛮简单的
Lucia: And the materials are pretty simple.
Lucia: 就丝带和串珠这些就行
Lucia: Just ribbons and beads and stuff.
Katrina:  那可以直接买材料包了
Katrina: Then we could just buy a material kit.
Lucia: 买材料包的话好像就没有那种环保的
Lucia: But if we buy a material kit, it's not as eco-friendly.
Katrina:  对特别环保的概念体现
Katrina: Yeah, it doesn't really show the eco-friendly concept.
Katrina:  那就那就得喝奶茶了哈哈
Katrina: So, we just need to drink milk tea, haha.
Lucia: 或者也可以
Lucia: Or we could...
Lucia: 应该应该
Lucia: Maybe, maybe...
Lucia: 淘宝上有那种包装
Lucia: There are those packages on Taobao.
Lucia: 也可以买一个我看看
Lucia: We could buy one, let me check.
Katrina:  但是你买包装跟买材料包感觉差不多
Katrina: But buying a package and a material kit seems the same.
Katrina:  意思确实
Katrina: It feels the same, really.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But it's just...
Lucia: 至少它给人的视觉效果是环保的
Lucia: At least it gives the visual effect of being eco-friendly.
Lucia: 至于它流
Lucia: As for the process,
Lucia: 程中这个就我们自行控制
Lucia: we can control it ourselves.
Katrina:  那应该没啥问题了
Katrina: That shouldn't be a problem.
Katrina:  然后可能嗯
Katrina: And then maybe um
Katrina:  如果要唱歌那种音响话筒这音调节
Katrina: If we need a sound system and microphone for singing, we should adjust the sound.
Jake: 我们之前让GPT出了几个plan
Jake: We had GPT come up with a few plans before.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  比如
Jake: 环保版
Shure: Like an eco-friendly version.
Jake: 你你说你画我猜
Jake: You know, like charades.
Katrina:  啊这个游戏呢
Jake: 啊这个是参与者
Jake: Ah, this is for the participants.
Jake: 可以设置参与者分组
Jake: You can set up participant groups.
Jake: 每组选择一个环保词汇
Jake: Each group chooses an eco-friendly word.
Jake: 如太阳能
Jake: Like solar power.
Jake: 拎废弃
Jake: Pick up waste.
Tasha: 循环
Jake: 啊还可以吧Jake
Jake: Ah, that works.
Tasha: 该怎么表达
Tasha: Not bad, how to express it?
Shure:  就是这种特别抽象的
Shure: It's something really abstract.
Shure:  然后大家就不好画
Shure: So it's hard for everyone to draw.
Lucia: 只能画吗
Lucia: Can only draw?
Lucia: 不能描述吗
Lucia: Can't describe it?
Jake: 画画
Jake: Draw.
Jake: 对啊不能说话了
Jake: Yeah, no talking allowed. OK.
Lucia:OK
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake:太阳能
Katrina:  那就设置在晚上吧
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  下午的时间不是很多
Katrina: There's not much time in the afternoon.
Katrina:  下午3点开始到5点半
Katrina: Starting from 3 PM to 5:30 PM.
Katrina:  就两个半小时
Katrina: Just two and a half hours.
Katrina:  介绍介绍
Katrina: Introduce and introduce.
Katrina:  逛一逛就差不多了
Katrina: Walk around and that's about it.
Jake: 嗯还有一个更离谱的
Jake: Mm, there's something even crazier.
Jake: 他的GDP确实厉害
Jake: Their GDP is indeed impressive.
Jake: 在沙盘或沙地中
Jake: In a sandbox or sandpit,
Jake: 隐藏一些微型塑料颗粒
Jake: hide some tiny plastic particles.
Jake: 参与者使用镊子和放大镜
Jake: Participants use tweezers and magnifying glasses.
Jake: 在规定时间内
Jake: Within the given time,
Jake: 尽可能找出这些塑料颗粒
Jake: try to find as many plastic particles as possible.
Jake: 哈哈这个游戏
Jake: Haha, this game
Katrina:  这个有点难
Jake: 这个游戏
Jake: This game
Jake: 可以让大家直观的认识到
Jake: can let everyone intuitively understand
Jake: 微塑料污染的隐蔽性
Jake: the hidden nature of microplastic pollution.
Jake: 哈哈哈很妙
Jake: Hahaha, very clever.
Jake: 这个GPT就是使唤人
Jake: This GPT is really bossing people around.
Jake: 哎呀使唤人挺能整
Jake: Wow, you're pretty good at bossing people around.
Shure:  完了你可不能像他学
Shure: Anyway, you shouldn't learn from him.
Lucia: 感觉像一种变相的寻宝
Shure:  听没听到
Shure: Did you hear that?
Lucia: 寻废品对
Lucia: Looking for junk, right?
Jake: 而且你这个头发还是遮住了
Jake: And your hair still covers it.
Jake: 要不还是我们
Jake: How about we...
Jake: 我们下午下午采购一波
Jake: We do some shopping this afternoon.
Shure:  对采购一波
Shure: Yeah, go shopping.
Shure:  采购一波发夹
Jake: 采购一波
Jake: Go shopping.
Katrina:  对下午要去采购是吗
Katrina: Yeah, are we going shopping this afternoon?
Jake: 嗯
Tasha: 这个吗
Katrina: Hmm, is it this one?
Shure:  对就是这种个人
Shure: Yeah, just like this.
Shure:  这种小别的那种
Shure: This small one.
Jake: 我们再看一圈吧
Jake: Let's take another look.
Jake: 我们其实不用
Jake: Actually, we don't need to...
Jake: 但是也看一眼
Jake: But let's take a look.
Lucia: 哎停住了
Lucia: Oh, it stopped.
Jake: 哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no.
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 我们其实剩下的一个人就行
Jake: We actually just need one more person.
Jake: 但是就转一圈比较稳妥
Jake: But it's safer to take another look around.
Katrina:  我发现这名片好好看
Katrina: I find this business card really nice.
Jake: 哦你们看那个你想活出怎样的人生
Jake: Oh, did you guys see that? "What kind of life do you want to live?"
Shure:  关崎骏那个
Shure: The Hayao Miyazaki one?
Katrina:  看没看懂
Katrina: Did you understand it?
Katrina:  后来看解析
Katrina: Then I watched the analysis.
Katrina:  了回来看解析
Katrina: Watched the analysis again later.
Katrina:  应该先看解析再去看
Katrina: Should've watched the analysis first.
Shure:  那些数字
Shure: Those numbers...
Alice: 他只有5%的电正充着电
Alice: He's only got 5% battery left, it's charging.
Alice: 他不会充的没用的快吧
Alice: It won't charge that fast, will it?
Jake: 呃不会不会不会不会
Jake: Uh, no, no, it won't.
Shure:  只要抱着太紧了就可以
Shure: As long as you hold it tight enough, it's fine.
Shure:  对
Katrina: OK那这就差不多敲定了
Jake: 差不多了那我们看看要准备什么吧
Jake: Almost done, let's see what we need to prepare.
Jake: 这几天
Jake: These...
Katrina:  嗯我想想啊就是各自买各自的材料
Katrina: Hmm, let me think, we each buy our own materials.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后要有音响和话筒如果要唱歌的话
Katrina: And we need speakers and a microphone if we want to sing.
Shure:  这个我都能搞定
Shure: I can handle that.
Jake: 意外啊
Katrina: 你本来就乐队的是吧
Jake: 啊你可以把音乐队都给弄来
Jake: Ah, you could bring the whole band.
Katrina:  我们当时就也总是那乐队同学带音响
Katrina: Back then, our bandmates would always bring the sound system.
Shure:  这这算商演吧应该
Shure: This should count as a commercial gig, right?
Katrina:  商演商演
Katrina: Commercial gig, commercial gig.
Jake: 商演商演
Jake: Commercial gig, commercial gig.
Jake: 学术商演学术商演学术商演
Jake: Academic commercial gig, academic commercial gig.
Jake: 在学术会议上面商演演唱会算什么呀
Jake: What does a concert at an academic conference even count as?
Jake: 你们接过这种活吗
Jake: Have you ever taken on such a gig?
Shure:  之前邀邀请过但是哦没没去
Shure: We got invited before but didn't go.
Shure:  没去有点太尴尬了主要是
Shure: Didn't go, it was too awkward.
Jake: 哦这下面人在看pose呢
Jake: Oh, people were watching the presentation.
Jake: 然后你在这瞅我
Jake: And you were staring at me.
Shure:  对对啊多尬呀我靠
Shure: Yeah, it was super awkward, gosh.
Katrina:  他那个呃你们买了什么
Katrina: What did you guys buy?
Katrina:  支架和小桌子吗
Katrina: Stands and a small table?
Jake: 嗯我们要不看看快递
Jake: Hmm, should we check the delivery?
Jake: 或者我们到处看一看吧
Jake: Or maybe we should look around.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 因为这个房间我们可能也要收拾收拾
Jake: Because this room, we might need to tidy it up.
Jake: 装饰装饰
Jake: Decorate a bit.
Katrina:  哦这个那我们是不是
Katrina Oh, so should we...
Katrina:  如果你要世界地球日为主题
Katrina: If you want a World Earth Day theme...
Katrina:  要买一点贴画呀
Katrina: You should get some stickers.
Jake: 对对对是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, totally.
Jake: 但是这个墙不能贴
Jake: But we can't stick things on the wall.
Jake: 我们也得想想办法怎么搞
Jake: We need to figure out a way.
Katrina:  有那种无痕贴的挂钩
Jake: 就是他就不不能贴这种墙
Katrina:  我知道
Katrina: I know.
Katrina:  我姐结婚的时候他们就是那种贴的
Katrina: My sister used those for her wedding.
Katrina:  就是酒店贴的
Katrina: The hotel used them.
Katrina:  可以撕下来就完全无痕的
Katrina: They peel off without leaving any marks.
Jake: OK如果很稳妥的话可以不然的话赔钱
Jake: OK, if it's safe, we can use them. Otherwise, we'll have to pay for damages.
Jake: 哈哈哈对这样砍了
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, that's right.
Katrina:  然后还有就是我们每个人的东西的话
Katrina: Also, for everyone's stuff...
Katrina:  他的甜品有自己的甜品家
Katrina: His desserts need a dessert stand.
Katrina:  那我们每个人
Katrina: So for everyone...
Katrina:  东西是不是也要有装桌子摆摊
Katrina: Should we get tables to display our things?
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Katrina: 因为那天呃
Shure: 去宜家采购一波吧
Shure:  20多人哈哈哈
Shure: More than 20 people, haha.
Jake: 过分了
Katrina: 直接给别墅主人贴新家具
Alice: 对啊一个够吗
Alice: Yeah, is one enough?
Alice: 还是要多买两个
Alice: Better buy two more.
Katrina:  你这一个是就是多少人可以一起玩
Katrina: How many people can play with just one of these?
Shure:  大概就一个人一起玩
Shure: Probably just one person.
Lucia: 哈哈哈两三个应该也行
Lucia: Haha, maybe two or three could work too.
Lucia: 再多其实买3个差不多
Lucia: Actually, buying three should be enough.
Jake: 我们要不玩一下
Jake: How about we play a bit?
Jake: 怎么玩对对对
Jake: How do we play?
Lucia: 我们先来试验一下
Lucia: Let's test it out first.
Shure:  我们这些这些都得试验一遍
Shure: We need to test all of these.
Shure:  就是甜品我们得先先吃一遍
Shure: We should try all the desserts first.
Katrina: 彩排
Shure:  然后烧烤也得先吃一遍
Shure: And then try the BBQ as well.
Lucia: 算盘打的
Lucia: That's some planning.
Alice: 这是一个支架的就不用管它
Alice: This is a stand, so no need to worry about it.
Shure:  毕竟其实这个比点外卖会便宜一些
Shure: After all, it's cheaper than ordering takeout.
Tasha: 什么会比点外卖便宜
Tasha: What’s cheaper than takeout?
Jake:什么东西
Shure:  就是比如说自己搞顿烧烤
Shure: Like, making your own BBQ.
Shure:  比点一桌子这样的烤串肯定会便宜
Shure: It's definitely cheaper than ordering a table full of skewers.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: 嗯那是这烧烤卖的可贵了
Jake: Yeah, BBQ sold outside is really pricey.
Jake:一根啥也不是
Shure: 一串四五块钱哦
Alice: 啪挺多
Alice: That adds up.
Jake: 哦看起来很难拼到吧
Jake: Oh, it looks hard to piece together.
Lucia: 确实不太好拼比较费时间
Lucia: Yeah, it’s quite time-consuming.
Tasha: 要怎么拼
Tasha: How do you piece it together?
Jake: 就把它给拼成一个圆啊
Jake: Just fit it into a circle.
Jake: 你要fit进去边缘
Jake: You have to fit the edges.
Shure:  这种弧形的都应该在边边
Shure: These curved pieces should go on the edges.
Jake: 他有可能骗你的吧
Jake: He might be tricking you.
Jake: 有会有可能吧
Jake: Possibly, right?
Tasha: 哎你这个明显就不在边边你这个
Tasha: Hey, this one obviously isn't on the edge.
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: That's wrong.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: No clue at all.
Jake: 一个都找到
Jake: Can't find one.
Lucia: 这个应该是在边边的这个
Lucia: This one should be on the edge.
Shure:  这个某一个边
Shure: This one on some edge.
Jake: 对一个边是在边边的
Jake: Yeah, one edge should be on the edge.
Lucia: 这个好像也能贴上
Lucia: This one seems to fit too.
Shure:  这不完全OK
Shure: It's not completely okay.
Jake: 他是一定会完全还是他他就会
Jake: He's definitely going to be fully or he will...
Katrina:  这个很适合放在安全性那边
Katrina: This is very suitable to put in the safety section.
Katrina:  让大家熟悉起来哦
Katrina: Let everyone get familiar with it.
Jake:啊啊啊对
Katrina:  这几个人坐在一起
Katrina: These few people sitting together.
Jake: 有那种特别大的玩一把
Jake: There's something really big to play.
Lucia:这个看起来
Tasha:哎我感觉这个是这样子的
Jake:哦
Tasha:惩罚
Lucia:很有可能
Tasha:这样
Shure:  哎呦
Tasha:是吧
Shure:  屌的嘞哈哈哈
Shure: That's awesome, hahaha.
Lucia: 感觉应该是看起来很
Lucia: It looks like it should be...
Lucia: 就是密合程度是比较高的
Lucia: The fit is pretty tight, hmm.
Tasha:嗯
Lucia: 那这个就是哎有可能
Lucia: So this one, well, maybe...
Shure: 这个在这的
Tasha: 天才三位天才诞生
Shure: 洒洒水啊
Shure:  这不两分钟搞定啊哈哈哈
Shure: This can be done in two minutes, hahaha.
Lucia: 这里是缺一个
Shure: 谁的脚比较啊
Alice: 哦不是完全拼合的
Alice: Oh, it's not completely aligned.
Alice: 还是有一点点缝缝的
Alice: There's still a little gap.
Jake:哦
Tasha: 不对
Alice:看一下答案吗
Shure:  不需要
Jake:不需要
Alice:就是你也记不住啊
Jake: 没有没有我们能拼出来
Jake: No, no, we can figure it out.
Jake: 能拼出来
Jake: We can figure it out.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们看答案
Shure: Hahaha, let's check the answer.
Shure:  开什么玩笑
Shure: What a joke!
Shure:  哈哈我觉得这个
Shure: Haha, I think this...
Lucia: 这个游戏参与度还是很高的
Lucia: This game is really engaging.
Alice: 反正你也记不住
Alice: Anyway, you won't remember.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我刚刚看到了跟他很像的在这里嗯
Tasha: I just saw something very similar to it here, hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  切不进去差一点点
Katrina: It won't fit, just a little bit off.
Jake: 嗯怎么一个靠谱的都找不到呢
Jake: Hmm, how come we can't find a reliable one?
Jake: 哈哈哈这算吗
Jake: Hahaha, does this count?
Jake: 这个这俩看起来不是颜色合缝
Jake: These two don't seem to match in color.
Lucia: 这是不是
Lucia: Is this...
Jake: 对他不是颜色合缝
Jake: Yeah, they don't match in color.
Katrina:  但是如果颜色合缝就很好找啊
Katrina: But if the colors matched, it would be easy to find.
Katrina:  找那个不同的他有可能有很多解法
Katrina: Finding the different one could have many solutions.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: Completely clueless.
Jake: 这可能就啥也没有啊
Jake: This might be nothing at all.
Jake: 逗你玩哈哈哈
Jake: Just messing with you, hahaha.
Tasha: 我觉得都没有一圈怎么回事
Tasha: I feel like it hasn't even made a full round, what's going on?
Jake: 对啊他面积都不够啊
Jake: Yeah, the area isn't enough.
Jake: 对我们要不直接往里面放吧
Jake: Yeah, should we just put it inside?
Jake: 你看能不能完了
Jake: See if you can finish it.
Shure:  哈哈哈急了有人急了
Shure: Hahaha someone's getting anxious.
Jake: 哈哈哈不是不是不是不是
Shure: Hahaha no, no, no, no.
Jake: Hahaha no, no, no, no.
Jake: 往里面放看看面积
Jake: Put it inside and see, maybe the area is about right.
Jake: 往里面放看看面积可能是差不多的吧
Lucia: 面积可能还是差不多的
Lucia: 看起来就是
Lucia: It looks like it.
Lucia: 这还有一些就感觉可能是差不多的
Lucia: There are still some left, it feels like it might be about right.
Lucia: 哎这是猫头鹰
Lucia: Hey, it's an owl.
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute!
Shure:  有人急了呀
Shure: Someone's getting anxious.
Alice: 这样看起来几个人一起玩也可以
Alice: It looks like several people playing together could work.
Alice: 是的是的挺好的这个东西
Alice: Yes, yes, this thing is pretty good.
Jake: 是的是的挺好的这个东西
Shure:  这也不是颜色盒
Shure: This isn't a color box either.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So hard.
Jake: 是什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 哈哈哈是小老鼠吗
Jake: Hahaha is it a little mouse?
Lucia: 是小老鼠吗
Lucia: 青蛙土地公公
Lucia: A frog land god.
Lucia: 青蛙
Katrina: 土地公公
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈咱们是野生动物
Katrina: Hahaha we are wild animals.
Shure: 我们是野生动物
Shure:  不是神话故事
Shure: Not mythological stories.
Shure:  还土地公公
Shure: Even land gods.
Jake: 野生神仙野生
Jake: Wild gods, wild.
Jake: 野生神仙
Lucia: 野生
Alice:它还亮着呢吗
Katrina:  特别像一个表情包
Katrina: It looks like an emoji.
Jake:没有
Jake: 没有怎么又不亮了
Jake: No, why isn't it lighting up again?
Alice:怎么又不亮了
Jake: 看一下是那边没插上
Jake: Check if it's plugged in over there.
Jake:我 看一下
Shure: 那边没插上吧
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Strange.
Alice: 但是他一直
Alice: But it always
Alice: 是35的电
Alice: It's 35 power.
Lucia: 不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Alice: 不好意思
Alice: 就没有
Lucia: Just not, um.
Lucia: 就没有嗯
Katrina:  我也是一直35
Katrina: Mine is always 35 too.
Jake: 对他电很多
Jake: Yeah, it has a lot of power.
Jake: 嗯不是
Jake: Hmm, no.
Shure:  他是一个2万毫安
Shure: It's a 20,000 mAh.
Jake:我看一下你的这个APP
Shure: Let me check your app.
Shure:  是我看一下你的这个APP
Tasha: 我觉得这个是这样子的
Jake: 我觉得这个是这样子
Jake: I think it's like this.
Katrina: 就是那软件吗
Katrina: Is it that software? Yes.
Katrina:  就是那软件吗对
Tasha: 这个是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Tasha: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯
Alice:但是它显示在记录啊
Jake: 差距差距就对了
Jake: The gap, the gap is correct.
Jake: 插进去就对了
Alice: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: 我看一下看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Alice:你看
Lucia: 这个能和它放在一起
Jake: 你是l你是L2是吗
Jake: You are L2, right?
Jake: 你是L2是吗
Alice:对
Jake: 灯坏了呵呵呵
Jake: The light is broken, haha.
Alice: 他在录但是
Alice: It's recording but...
Lucia: 他是就是是不是自动
Lucia: Is it automatic?
Lucia: 自动监测
Lucia: Auto-detect.
Lucia: 觉得现在这个环境不需要开灯
Lucia: It thinks the current environment doesn't need the light.
Jake: 没有不是不是不是这个
Jake: No, no, no, not this.
Jake: 这个是为了保护被拍摄人的隐私啊
Jake: This is to protect the privacy of the person being filmed.
Jake: 被拍摄人知道自己
Jake: The person being filmed knows...
Jake: 对对对哦OK
Jake: Yes, yes, okay.
Jake: 但是其实拍摄人不知道
Jake: But actually, the filmer doesn't know.
Jake: 但是呵呵
Jake: But, haha...
Jake: 拍摄人应该会感觉到吧
Jake: The filmer should be able to feel it, right?
Lucia: 啊了胜于无对
Jake: 啊了胜于无对
Jake: Something is better than nothing, right?
Jake: 再输一下
Jake: Try again.
Jake: 他
Jake: He...
Jake: 刚刚其实是软件没有更新你的状态
Jake: Actually, the software didn't update your status just now.
Jake: 所以你是没有在录
Jake: So you weren't recording.
Jake: 但是软件上也是我在录
Jake: But on the software, it showed I was recording.
Jake: 这个应该
Jake: 所以这
Jake: So...
Alice:我按照现在的时间吧
Lucia: 个到底是什么
Lucia: What exactly is this?
Lucia: 这个到底是什么
Lucia: 还有5个角哎
Lucia: It has five corners.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Hmm, yes.
Jake: 你按照现在的事情
Jake: According to the current situation...
Jake: 你按照现在的时间
Lucia: 神奇就是蛤蟆这个
Lucia: Amazing, like a toad.
Lucia: 神奇
Jake: 哈哈哈估计最后才能放吧
Jake: Haha, it'll probably be released last.
Tasha: 这是什么
Jake: 这是大嘴鸟是吧
Jake: This is a toucan, right?
Tasha: 哦我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake: 哦我靠
Lucia: 好抽象啊
Lucia: So abstract.
Jake: 大嘴鸟
Jake: A toucan.
Jake: 这个也很抽象
Jake: This is also very abstract.
Jake: 谁家牛长这样
Jake: Whose cow looks like this?
Shure:  野牛啊水牛
Shure: A wild buffalo or a water buffalo.
Jake: 那水牛为什么下面会长稻草
Jake: Then why does the water buffalo have straw underneath?
Alice: 他站在草上
Alice: It's standing on grass.
Shure:  毛很长
Shure:  毛很长这个这个
Shure: Its hair is long, this, this...
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: 是不是他这一边
Lucia: Is it this side?
Lucia: 是哎对
Lucia: Yes, that's right.
Shure:  他叫牦牛
Shure: He calls it a yak.
Shure:  对这个很妙
Shure: Yeah, that's amazing.
Jake: 嗯这个太妙了
Jake: Hmm, that's really amazing.
Jake: 然后既然是这一边的话
Jake: And since it's on this side...
Lucia: 然后既然是这一边的话
Lucia: 那这里应该有一个能放的东西
Lucia: Then there should be something to put here.
Alice: 尖尖的
Alice: Something pointy.
Lucia: 好像不是耶
Lucia: It doesn't seem like it.
Shure:  不是CPU白烧了
Shure: If not, the CPU would be wasted.
Shure:  完了CPU干烧了
Shure:  AI快给我一个解法
Shure: AI, give me a solution quickly.
Jake: 大家一直在看时间
Jake: Everyone keeps looking at the time.
Jake: 看秒表这个数据
Jake: Watching the stopwatch data.
Katrina:  看这个书为了干啥
Katrina: Why are we reading this book?
Katrina:  为了同步
Katrina: For synchronization.
Jake: 回头就是在某一个帧上面把时间写上
Jake: Later, just write the time on a specific frame.
Jake: 哦明白了
Jake: Oh, I get it.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Eh.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: This is so hard.
Jake: 这个会在边上吗
Jake: Will this be at the edge?
Jake: 还有没有边了
Jake: Is there any edge left?
Lucia: 这个边怎么给人一种不太够的感觉
Lucia: This edge gives a feeling of not being enough.
Lucia: 他这不是严丝合缝的
Lucia: 他这不是颜色和风
Lucia: Isn't this about color and style?
Alice: 有的是差不多的那种
Alice: Some are almost the same.
Alice: 嗯这回是比较不太像
Alice: Hmm, this time it's not quite like that.
Jake: 要不还是全放进去吧
Jake: Why not just put everything in?
Jake: 哈哈全放进去
Jake: Haha, put everything in.
Jake: 先看一看他乱拼的话差多少
Jake: First, let's see how much it differs if it's all mixed up.
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位置
Tasha: This bird takes up so much space.
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位
Katrina:  所有的都可以放进去
Katrina: Everything can go in.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake: 刚刚就是这么拿出来的
Jake: That's how we just took it out.
Alice:不是不是外面的
Shure:  比那个大
Shure: It's not the bigger one.
Shure:  比那个不是大只的哦
Tasha: 那就塞个你
Jake: Then let's stuff you in.
Jake: 那就塞个你
Tasha: 你塞不进去换一个
Tasha: If you can't fit, try another one.
Tasha: 你也塞不进去
Tasha: You can't fit either.
Katrina:  我们塞他
Katrina: Let's stuff him.
Lucia: 这啥这是刺猬吗
Lucia: What is this, a hedgehog?
Alice: 哈哈可以
Alice: Haha, could be.
Tasha: 他肯定就在这了
Tasha: It must be here.
Tasha: 土地公公在她的胯下
Tasha: 哦就是我以为他是太阳公公的胯下
Tasha: Oh, I thought it was under the sun god's crotch.
Lucia: 哦就是我以为他是
Lucia: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳
Tasha: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳流氓
Tasha: Look hahaha, doesn't it look like a sun gangster?
Lucia: 我觉得这个太阳应该很好找到对应的
Lucia: I think this sun should be easy to match.
Lucia: 就因为他这里有很多的刺
Lucia: Just because it has a lot of spikes here.
Lucia: 所以这边我觉得这个是这个
Lucia: 所以这边我觉得这个是这个特别像耶
Lucia: So I think this one looks really similar.
Jake:特别像耶
Jake: 哇这个这个太严格了吧
Jake: Wow, this is too strict.
Lucia: 耶
Jake: 我去
Jake: Yeah, come on.
Jake: 耶我去
Jake: 这太严格了
Jake: This is too strict.
Jake: 如果都是这种严格程度的话
Jake: If everything is this strict,
Alice:那就好找了
Jake: 那就好找了
Jake: then it will be easy to find.
Lucia: 胜利
Alice: 胜利又顺利找到一个
Alice: Victory, we found another one successfully.
Alice: 谁没家
Alice: 谁没加
Alice: Who hasn't added it?
Alice: 如今你四海为家
Alice: Now you are a wanderer.
Shure:  如今你四海为家
Tasha: 怎么办还有这么多人没有家
Tasha: What to do, so many people still don't have a home.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  回家回回家
Shure: Go home, go home.
Shure:  回家回家
Shure:  回家是最好的礼物
Shure: Going home is the best gift.
Jake: 放BGM吧
Jake: Play the BGM.
Jake: 要不BGM再继续进去
Jake: Or we can continue with the BGM.
Shure:  这时候应该放这个怎么办
Shure: At this moment, we should play this, what to do.
Tasha: 怎么办
Alice: 是不是标注一下
Alice: Should we mark it?
Alice: 为什么这时候要放这个
Alice: Why play this at this moment?
Alice: 为什么这时候要放
Alice: 好像真的是在这的
Alice: It really seems like it fits here.
Tasha: 这个 好像真的是在这的
Tasha: 嗯是吧
Tasha: Yeah, right?
Jake: 嗯很难很难说
Jake: Hmm, it's hard to say.
Jake: 好吧不是有可能
Jake: Alright, maybe not.
Tasha: 好吧不是
Jake: 有可能
Lucia: 能让AI把这些轮廓都扫描一下
Lucia: Can we have AI scan these outlines?
Lucia: 然后让他帮忙拼吗
Lucia: And then have it help us piece them together?
Lucia: 嗯试试
Lucia: Yeah, let's try.
Jake:嗯试试
Alice: 无限次试
Alice: Unlimited tries.
Alice: 对反正他算的快
Alice: Yeah, since it calculates fast.
Lucia: 对就是应该有这种类似的软件吧
Lucia: Yeah, there should be software like this, right?
Lucia: 不然就是那种乐高都是怎么设计的
Lucia: Otherwise, how are those Legos designed?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 动物世界
Alice: Animal World.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈这个应该是这样子的吧
Alice: Hahaha, it should be like this, right?
Tasha: 这个应该是这样子的吧
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, yeah.
Lucia: 很像很像
Lucia: Very similar.
Lucia: 应该是的
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 嗯好厉害
Lucia: Yeah, amazing.
Tasha: 他们俩捆绑了
Tasha: They are tied together.
Tasha: 对就是把
Tasha: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 只要把那
Lucia: As long as you put that...
Lucia: 个能合上的都放在一起先
Lucia: All the pieces that fit together first.
Lucia: 然后再看他们具体是个怎么回事把
Lucia: Then we'll figure out what's going on with them.
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来对对
Tasha: Take out the ones that don't fit, right.
Lucia: 对对
Alice: 他俩是不是
Alice: Are those two...
Alice: 这个肯定在边上
Alice: This one should be on the side.
Lucia: 这个肯定在边上
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下他仨
Lucia: So we can place this one with those three.
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下
Lucia: 但是这他这个这么明显
Lucia: But this one is so obvious.
Lucia: 应该会有一个
Lucia: There should be one...
Alice: 他俩像不像一家的感觉
Alice: Don't these two seem like they're from the same set?
Alice: 是一家的他们俩像一家的
Alice: They're from the same set, those two look alike.
Tasha: 他们俩像一家的
Tasha: 他就没有那么一家他
Tasha: He doesn't quite fit the set.
Tasha: 这样子吧
Alice: How about this...
Alice: 这样子吧
Tasha: 中间能不能再塞一条东西这个
Tasha: Can we squeeze something in the middle here?
Lucia: 是不是有点像啊
Lucia: Does it kinda look like it?
Jake: 反过来不至于
Jake: Turning it around wouldn't be necessary.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 或者在这里面谁是条条的
Alice: Or who in here is stripy?
Tasha: 他他不一定对
Tasha: He, he might not be right.
Tasha: 他拿走这这些小家伙都不对
Tasha: He took these little guys, and they're not right.
Tasha: 这个有有谁是长成这样的
Tasha: This one, who looks like this?
Tasha: 这样吗可以这个样子哦
Tasha: Like this? Can it be like this, oh.
Shure:  在中间留着一点
Shure: Leave a bit in the middle.
Shure:  然后这样哦
Shure: Then like this, oh.
Lucia: 有道理就可以
Lucia: Makes sense, that could work.
Lucia: 看这个和这两边感觉就比较哎
Lucia: See, this one and these two sides, it kinda feels, hey.
Tasha: 找刚刚找的那个呢
Tasha: Where's the one we just found?
Tasha: 哦不是
Tasha: Oh, no.
Tasha: 我还找了一个呢
Tasha: I found another one.
Tasha: 我把它拆了
Tasha: I took it apart.
Alice: 拆成他俩了
Alice: You split it into two?
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧行哦
Alice: So this is the one you were talking about, right? Okay.
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧行
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: 他又在上去存疑
Tasha: He's doubtful about it again.
Tasha: 他有待商榷存疑
Alice:它俩像吗
Alice: 完了咱他俩这么长时间都没拼出来
Alice: Oh no, we haven't put it together after all this time.
Lucia: 完了咱他俩这么长时间都没拼出来
Lucia: 要是放到下午大家拼可能也拼不出来
Lucia: Even if we tried in the afternoon, we might not finish it.
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧对
Katrina: Let them play all afternoon, right?
Jake:对
Katrina:  这拼出来了给多少金币
Katrina: How many coins for completing this?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 这个为什么在摸他的屁股
Tasha: Why is this one touching his butt?
Tasha: 然后这个蹲在他的屁股上
Tasha: And this one is squatting on his butt.
Tasha: 哈哈哈你是来拉屎的吧
Tasha: Hahaha, are you here to poop?
Shure: 你是来拉屎的吧
Tasha: 哈哈哈真的是这样放的吗
Tasha: Hahaha, is this really how you place it?
Lucia: 哈哈也可能不是
Tasha: Haha, maybe not.
Tasha: 哈哈也可能不是
Shure:  这绝对不是
Shure: Definitely not.
Shure:  太变态了
Shure: That's too perverted.
Tasha: 好了只有目前这些是确定的
Tasha: Alright, that's all we know for now.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 他的这个脚肯定
Alice: His foot definitely...
Lucia: 吗不太可能
Lucia: Not likely.
Shure:  这个脚肯定插到谁的屁股里
Shure: His foot is definitely stuck in someone's butt.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 这个在这的
Tasha: This one is here.
Alice: 他揭着他的屁股好
Alice: He's lifting his butt up.
Alice: 他接着他的屁股好
Alice: 好尴尬
Alice: So awkward.
Tasha: 刚刚谁说他是土地公公的
Tasha: Who just said he's the Earth God?
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一起哇
Alice: Hey, can these two be together?
Lucia: 好了哇
Lucia: Okay, wow.
Tasha: 好了哇
Alice: 再来一个
Alice: Let's do another one.
Alice: 好厉害
Alice: Amazing.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: Feels like victory is in sight.
Tasha: 三人游戏
Tasha: Three-person game.
Jake: 三人游戏
Jake: Three-person game.
Shure:  三人游戏
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake: 这是个什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 这是个猴子吧
Lucia: It's a monkey, right?
Lucia: 好像哦是的
Lucia: Seems like it, oh yes.
Alice: 哎这样也挺挺搭的
Alice: Hey, this actually looks quite fitting.
Alice: 像吗哎
Alice: Doesn't it?
Jake: 像吗
Jake: 一般像吧
Jake: Looks like it, doesn't it?
Jake: 好像班像吧
Tasha: 亚班吧有可能吧
Tasha: Yeah, maybe.
Tasha: 两般吧
Jake: 有可能
Alice:像吗一般像
Jake: 一般像
Jake: Looks like it, generally like it.
Jake: 像吗一般像一般像
Tasha: 两个细长条形的
Tasha: Two long and thin shapes.
Jake: 这片头多久啊
Jake: How long is this intro?
Jake: 几分钟刚刚的
Jake: Just a few minutes ago.
Jake: 动物世界
Jake: 动物世界4分32秒
Jake: Animal World, 4 minutes and 32 seconds.
Shure: 4分32秒
Shure:  哈哈什么东西
Shure: Haha, what?
Jake: 刚刚那个动物世界
Jake: That Animal World just now.
Jake: 4分32秒已经悄悄的过去了
Jake: 4 minutes and 32 seconds have quietly passed.
Tasha: 才过去4分钟吗
Tasha: It's only been 4 minutes?
Tasha: 嗯哈哈
Tasha: Hmm haha.
Jake: 还好还好
Jake: That's okay, that's okay.
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全对
Lucia: Why does it feel like this curved edge is completely off?
Jake:对
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
Tasha: 这个算是
Tasha: 这个算是反了
Tasha: This one is reversed.
Alice:反了
Tasha: 是吧哎
Alice: Right, huh.
Alice: 是吧哎
Alice:反了吧
Alice: It's reversed, isn't it? No, it's not.
Alice: 反了吧没反
Tasha: 没没
Alice: 嗯就这颜色
Alice: Yeah, it's just this color.
Tasha: 我不想
Tasha: I don't want to.
Lucia: 我不想
Tasha: 哎你刚不是把那个放在一起了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you just put that together?
Alice: 疑似
Alice: Suspected.
Alice: 也不想
Alice: I don't want to either.
Lucia: 他到底是哪一边
Lucia: Which side is it?
Alice: 他是来迷惑你的
Alice: It's here to confuse you.
Lucia: 感觉两个好像都可以
Lucia: Feels like both sides could work.
Tasha: 不太像这么大啊
Tasha: Doesn't seem that big, does it?
Alice: 不太像这么大啊
Shure:  血压高了怎么办
Shure: What if blood pressure rises?
Shure:  哎会是这样的
Shure: Oh, it could be like this.
Lucia: 哎会是这样的
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 这个是在这个边边上吗
Tasha: Is this on the edge?
Tasha: 这个是在边边上
Tasha: This is on the edge.
Lucia: don't you
Lucia: Don't you...
Jake: 拆快递吧
Jake: Let's open the package.
Jake: 要不哈哈
Jake: Or, haha.
Alice:啊
Jake: 啊拆快递拆快递拆快递拆快递
Jake: Ah, open the package, open the package, open the package.
Jake: 拆快递拆快递拆快递拆快递
Katrina:  我去把我的花不行了
Katrina: I'm going to get my flower, it's not doing well.
Shure:  血压高了
Shure: Blood pressure is high.
Tasha: 怎么怎么回事
Alice: 怎么怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
Jake: 拆拆一会回来
Jake: Open it, we'll come back later.
Jake: 呃呃就有灵感了
Jake: Uh, uh, then we'll have inspiration.
Tasha:  在哪拆快递
Jake: 在哪拆快递
Jake: Where to open the package?
Jake: 呃那边有一些快递
Jake: Uh, there are some packages over there.
Jake: 然后就过来拆
Jake: Then just come over and open them.
Katrina:  我要整一波我的
Katrina: I need to organize my stuff.
Katrina:  我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Katrina: I still have some at the parcel station.
Tasha: 我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Tasha:  嗯
Jake: 嗯哦我看一下他们
Jake: Hmm, let me take a look at them.
Jake: 哦我看一下他们
Shure:  哪里是你的
Shure: Where is yours?
Katrina:  都是我的都是你的
Katrina: It's all mine, it's all yours.
Katrina:  这这也是我的哎
Katrina: This, this is also mine, hey.
Katrina:  有剪刀吗有有有
Katrina: Do you have scissors? Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina:  有剪刀吗
Tasha: 这俩脚
Tasha: These two feet.
Alice:: 哈哈
Katrina:  哈哈好奇怪啊
Katrina: Haha, so weird.
Lucia: 好奇怪啊
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could it be?
Katrina:  这买多少个来着
Katrina: How many did we buy?
Alice: 它会不会是在边边
Katrina:  汉服不是在边边
Katrina: Isn't the Hanfu on the edge?
Alice: 他在边也
Lucia: It's on the edge, too.
Lucia: 他在边也
Tasha: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: 这个有没有一点苦
Lucia: Is this a bit bitter?
Lucia: 这个有没有一点
Lucia: 有没有一点点像啊有可能
Lucia: Does it look a little bit like it? Maybe.
Lucia: 有没有一点点像啊
Alice:有可能
Shure:  what's this
Shure: What's this?
Katrina:  这就是压花器
Katrina: This is a flower press.
Katrina:  就是你把那个鲜花放进去
Katrina: You put fresh flowers in it.
Katrina:  它就会变成干花
Katrina: They turn into dried flowers.
Tasha: 这么粗买几个
Tasha: How many did we buy this thick?
Tasha: 怎么说朋友们
Tasha: 一个哎三三个
Tasha: One, uh, three.
Tasha: 别把他漏了
Tasha: Don't lose it.
Tasha: 4个漏出来
Tasha: Four slipped out.
Lucia: 这个地方他偏平一点
Lucia: This part is a bit flatter.
Lucia: 这是不是一个相对平坦的一个
Lucia: Is this a relatively flat one?
Lucia: 嗯显得太小
Lucia: Hmm, it looks too small.
Lucia: 有可能会是这样
Lucia: It might be like this.
Tasha: 啊不行啊他好像太平了
Tasha: Ah, no, this is too flat.
Tasha: 啊不行啊这是太平了
Tasha: 也许是呢
Tasha: The clothes are wet.
Tasha: 衣服湿了
Lucia: 一般相似先放在这里好了
Lucia: Usually similar ones are placed here first.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: 那把它按在这里面的哪里呢
Tasha: Then where do we press it inside here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈好问题
Lucia: Haha, good question.
Lucia: 这个有可能吧
Lucia: This might be possible.
Lucia: 是不是也不太可能呀
Lucia: Or maybe not possible.
Lucia: 好迷惑啊我
Lucia: I'm so confused.
Lucia: 我小时候玩那个1,000块拼图
Lucia: When I was a kid, I used to play with 1,000-piece puzzles.
Lucia: 从来没有拼出来过
Lucia: I never finished one.
Tasha: 真的吗对我每次后面有数字
Tasha: Really? Yes, there were always numbers on the back.
Tasha: 真的吗  他后面有数字
Lucia: 对
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Lucia: 啊是吗
Katrina:  是呀哎
Katrina: Yes, hey.
Lucia: 那难道我买的是盗版的
Lucia: Did I buy a bootleg one then?
Lucia: 反正我就是
Lucia: Anyway, I...
Lucia: 我好不容易拼了其中的一部分
Lucia: I barely managed to finish a part of it.
Lucia: 然后就不会拼了
Lucia: Then I just couldn't spell it.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃
Lucia: So I gave up.
Lucia: 好难呀
Lucia: It's so hard. What should I do if I'm tired?
Lucia: 好难呀玩困了怎么办
Alice: 玩困了怎么办怎么说呢催眠了
Alice: How should I put this? This should be hypnotic.
Alice: 怎么说呢这个应该催眠了
Tasha: 在这的
Tasha: 喝杯咖啡吧
Tasha: Have a cup of coffee.
Tasha: 那这个
Shure: 喝杯咖啡喝
Tasha: Yeah, have a cup of coffee.
Tasha: 嗯喝杯咖啡喝
Lucia: 太难了
Lucia: It's too hard.
Alice: 感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Lucia: It feels like they can do this too.
Lucia: 速度感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Tasha: 就一点点就成这样了
Tasha: Just a little bit and it's already like this.
Tasha: 就这样了
Shure:  这么多
Shure: This much?
Katrina:  对但是我以为每
Katrina: Yes, but I thought everyone
Katrina:  个人都要做
Katrina: would have to do it.
Katrina:  一到两边边都不播放了
Katrina: Both sides won't play anymore.
Tasha: 边都不够放了
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha: 大家挤一挤
Tasha: Everyone squeeze in.
Lucia: 哈哈边不够了
Tasha: 哈哈电不够了
Tasha: Haha, the power's running out.
Tasha: 嗯大家积极勉强
Tasha: Hmm, everyone try their best.
Tasha: 嗯大家挤挤了
Tasha: 哎就这样
Tasha: Sigh, just like this.
Katrina:  就是这样的哈哈
Katrina: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 就是这样的哈哈
Lucia: 非常对
Lucia: Exactly.
Tasha: 我感觉边是对了但我感觉这有点大
Tasha: I feel like the sides are right, but this part feels a bit big.
Tasha: 我感觉边是对了
Alice:要不然这有点大
Alice: 嗯但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Alice: Hmm, but I think this part needs to be reassembled.
Tasha: 但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Tasha: 我觉得这边没问题
Tasha: I think this part is fine.
Tasha: 这边这边有问题
Tasha: This part, this part has a problem.
Tasha: 要把这几个重新组合一下
Tasha: We need to reassemble these few pieces.
Tasha: 但还是这几个边
Tasha: But still, these sides.
Lucia: 总感觉这个牛
Lucia: It always feels like this is awesome.
Lucia: 这里他应该能放一个什么东西进来
Lucia: Here, he should be able to put something in.
Lucia: 但是是的
Lucia: But yes.
Tasha: 是的
Lucia: 难道他也是一个
Lucia: Could it be a trick?
Lucia: 障眼法吗
Lucia: An illusion?
Katrina:  这样就可以扩延充足
Katrina: This way, it can be extended sufficiently.
Tasha: 我怎么放不进来呢
Lucia: 这个看起来其实也像在边上一样
Lucia: This actually looks like it's on the side too.
Lucia: 看就是如果如果这样的话是吧
Lucia: Look, if it's like this, right?
Katrina:  你这个花瓶呢
Katrina: Where's your vase?
Katrina:  快递在哪看到的哦
Katrina: Where did you see the delivery?
Tasha: 花瓶不是快递
Tasha: The vase isn't the delivery.
Alice: 花瓶不是快递
Alice: 就在桌子上
Alice: It's on the table.
Alice: 有两个瓶子
Alice: There are two vases.
Tasha: 哎这个是不是
Tasha: 哎这个哎我买了6啊
Tasha: Oh, this one. Oh, I bought six of them.
Tasha: 啊
Jake: 哪一个
Jake: 哪一个取得了历史性的进步啊
Jake: Which one made historical progress?
Tasha: 取得了历史性的进步啊
Tasha: 哈哈哈我们刚发现这是这样的
Tasha: Hahaha, we just discovered it’s like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们刚发现这是这样的
Lucia: 然后这样又可以拼上哦
Lucia: Then we can piece it together like this.
Jake:哦秒啊
Shure:  历史性的进步
Shure: Historical progress.
Tasha: 取得历史性的进步
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 胜利在望哈哈
Lucia: Victory is in sight, haha.
Jake: 你买了几个花瓶
Jake: How many vases did you buy?
Katrina:  6个我当时想的是一人一个放下
Katrina: Six. I thought we could each place one.
Lucia: 立几个flag
Tasha: 放呀
Katrina:  嗯6个花瓶
Katrina: Hmm, six vases.
Shure: 放不下啊
Jake: 厨房看到了吗
Jake: Did you see the kitchen?
Jake: 看到了几个
Jake: How many did you see?
Jake: 我看看都到了没
Jake: Let me check if they all arrived.
Katrina:  好像都到了
Katrina: Seems like they all arrived.
Shure:  这个跟这个上的
Shure: This one goes with this one.
Tasha: 这个在边上的
Alice: 但是这感觉
Alice: But this feels...
Lucia: 这个有可能在里面
Lucia: This one might be inside.
Lucia: 感觉它看起来好像都不太圆对吧
Lucia: It looks like it’s not very round, right?
Tasha: 嗯先把它放出来吧
Lucia: Hmm, let's place it first.
Lucia: 嗯先把它放
Tasha: 这个熊猫
Lucia: 哎这个也很像在边上
Lucia: Panda, this one also looks like it's on the side.
Lucia: 熊猫哎这个也很像在边上
Katrina:  有道理确实发了三个快递
Katrina: Makes sense. We did receive three packages.
Katrina:  但是都到了
Katrina: But they all arrived.
Katrina:  你们换个边
Katrina: You guys switch sides.
Alice: 你们换个边
Alice: 更不像哎
Alice: Looks even less like it.
Tasha: 这个感觉屏有点那种弧度是他吗
Tasha: This screen seems to have that kind of curve. Is it this one?
Alice: 不是不是这个也不是
Alice: No, no, it’s not this one either.
Lucia: 如果把那个鸟嘴冲着那边就是
Lucia: If we point the bird's beak that way, then...
Lucia: 这样的话嗯好像也放不进去
Lucia: Like this, hmm, it still doesn't fit.
Lucia: 这些东西有可能吗
Lucia: Could these things fit?
Jake: 哎我拼几个这个吧
Jake: Let me piece a few of these together.
Jake: 这个有用吗
Jake: Is this useful?
Jake: 这个这个要不
Jake: How about this one?
Jake: 把白板给放下去也不行
Jake: Putting the whiteboard down doesn’t work either.
Jake: 把白板给放下去
Jake: 就是把白板给赶到这个上面就不行了
Jake: If we push the whiteboard onto this, it still won’t work.
Jake: 就是把白板给赶到这个上面
Lucia: 这个呢就不信了
Shure:  要的怎么写太费劲了
Shure: Writing on it is too much trouble.
Katrina:  花都在这
Katrina: All the flowers are here.
Katrina:  哇你已经弄好了
Katrina: Wow, you already set it up.
Lucia: 剪刀怎么会弄剪刀
Lucia: How did you manage the scissors?
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Tasha: 先把这个放上
Katrina:  剪刀在外面
Katrina: The scissors are outside.
Katrina:  这加水了吗
Katrina: Did you add water to this?
Katrina:  加过了加过了
Katrina: Yes, I did.
Jake:加过了
Katrina:  加过了
Katrina:  是吧
Katrina: Right?
Jake:是吧
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 哇哇
Lucia: Wow, wow.
Alice: 太难了拼图天才
Alice: This is so hard, puzzle genius.
Alice: 太难了
Tasha: 拼图天才
Alice: 哈哈天才又找到一块
Alice: Haha, the genius found another piece.
Lucia:  哈哈天才又找到一块
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: Puzzle genius.
Tasha: 出世出山
Tasha: Making an appearance.
Jake: 真有意思
Jake: So interesting.
Lucia: 让我们看看有没有可能
Lucia: Let's see if it's possible.
Lucia: 在不依靠
Lucia: Without relying on...
Lucia: 解析的情况下
Lucia: Analysis.
Jake: 这尾巴试过
Jake: Tried this tail.
Alice: 有点大
Alice: A bit big.
Lucia: 这个呢有可能
Lucia: How about this one, maybe?
Lucia: 不太行
Lucia: Not really working.
Lucia: 现在谁在中间呢
Lucia: Who's in the middle now?
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个好像不太行
Tasha: Hmm, this one doesn't seem to work.
Lucia: 好像不太行
Alice: 他又跟谁分家了
Alice: Who's he splitting with now?
Tasha: 对他他在这
Tasha: Yeah, he's here.
Alice: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Tasha: Oh, lost his buddy.
Tasha: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Lucia: 哦这个这个这个在他的
Lucia: Oh, this, this, this one is with...
Lucia: sorry忘记了
Lucia: Sorry, forgot.
Tasha: 嗯对这儿拼好了的
Lucia: Hmm, right, it's like this.
Lucia: 嗯对这是这样子的
Lucia: 对对对这块就这样挺好
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, this piece is good.
Tasha: 这样子挺好的
Tasha: Yeah, this is good.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one...
Tasha: 这个还不确定在哪
Tasha: Not sure where this goes.
Alice: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Alice: 确定在放中间吧
Tasha: Put it in the middle?
Tasha: 确定在放中间吧
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像
Alice: Do you think this fits?
Lucia: 像
Tasha: 像嗯
Tasha: Looks like it, hmm.
Alice: 好好先找找你的位置
Tasha: Okay, let's find your spot first.
Tasha: 好好先找找你的位置
Katrina:  所有快递都在外面了吗
Katrina:  所有快递都在外面了吗对
Katrina: Are all the packages outside? Yes?
Jake:对
Jake: 今天还到了几个
Jake: A few more came today.
Jake: 但是还都会有管家过来送
Jake: But the butler will come to deliver them.
Shure:  还有管家
Shure: There's a butler?
Shure:  那他能把我的送来吗
Shure: Can he deliver mine too?
Tasha: 那他能把我的送来吗
Jake: 什么东西啊
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 把什么东西
Jake: What thing?
Tasha: 杨明我买的东西
Tasha: Yang Ming, the stuff I bought.
Tasha: 把我买的东西
Tasha: 那应该是很好的
Tasha: That should be good.
Katrina:  那应该是很好的
Jake: 可以啊今天会有吗没有
Jake: Alright, will there be one today? No?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: 我问一下他们什么时候能
Jake: I'll ask them when they can...
Jake: 能来送
Jake: ...come and deliver.
Tasha: 好这游戏三个人玩刚刚好我们的
Tasha: Okay, this game is perfect for three players.
Alice: 掌管120组
Alice: Managing 120 groups.
Alice: 每个人掌管120度
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 不太像
Lucia: Doesn't seem like it.
Alice: 他俩是不是一家的
Alice: Are those two from the same family?
Tasha: 他们仨是不是一个家的
Tasha: Are those three from the same family?
Lucia: 有可能但是总觉得哎
Lucia: Maybe, but I always feel like, hmm...
Lucia: 这里是不是应该稍微弧度再推一点
Lucia: Should we push this curve a bit more here?
Tasha: 可是感觉不是那么严丝合缝
Tasha: But it doesn't feel like it's that tight.
Tasha: 他们俩的宽度最匹配
Tasha: The width of these two matches the best.
Lucia: 然后放一下
Lucia: Then put it down.
Lucia: 姑且然后放一下
Tasha: 或者这个呢
Tasha: Holding onto this?
Tasha: 抱着这个呢
Tasha: 这两个都有可能
Tasha: Both of these are possible.
Katrina:  要帮忙不
Katrina: Need help?
Tasha: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Tasha: Hey, do you think this looks like it goes here?
Alice: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Tasha: 这样子的这样
Tasha: Like this, like this?
Lucia: 哎是这样只的
Katrina:  像不像这是什么呀
Katrina: Does this look like... what is this?
Alice:像不像这是什么呀
Katrina:  我感觉这个可以
Katrina: I think this works.
Alice: 我感觉这个跟哪都行
Katrina:  不喜欢拧螺丝
Katrina: I don't like screwing screws.
Alice: 不过这个头对着他的屁股
Alice: But this head is facing his butt.
Alice: 好像也挺严丝合缝的
Alice: 好像也挺颜色合缝的
Alice: It seems to fit quite well.
Tasha: 这个这个是对的
Tasha: This, this is correct.
Jake: 喜欢拧螺丝
Jake: Likes screwing screws.
Jake: 就是刚刚拧的太紧了
Jake: Just screwed it too tight earlier.
Lucia: 我们能配对
Jake: 对对要不装个鸡
Jake: Yeah, yeah, how about we install a chicken?
Tasha: 我们俩俩配对
Tasha: 咱俩配对啊
Tasha: Shall we pair up?
Shure:  要不咱装个机
Shure:  要不咱装个鸡
Shure: How about we install a chicken?
Shure:  好给你买一个台电脑
Shure: Okay, I'll get you a computer.
Jake: 从头装哇
Jake: Install from scratch, wow.
Jake: 怎么出来的
Jake: How did it come out?
Tasha: 这个是吗
Tasha: Is this it?
Alice: 有长这样的吗
Tasha: Does it look like this?
Tasha: 有长这样的吗
Alice: 没有吧这个也有点像
Alice: No, but this one looks a bit like it.
Alice: 没有吧
Tasha: 嗯因为很
Lucia: 嗯因为好像长这样的弄出来的
Lucia: Yeah, because it seems like it's made like this.
Lucia: 长这样的
Alice:没有应该不是
Shure:  这不像应该不是
Shure: Doesn't look like it, probably not.
Tasha: 这个暂且配对吧
Tasha: Let's pair this for now.
Alice: 这我感觉这样应该
Alice: I feel like this should be...
Alice: 这啥意思
Alice: What does this mean?
Alice: 很勉强但不是不行
Alice: It's barely possible but not impossible.
Jake: 试试笔画
Jake: Try the strokes.
Tasha: 这个跟谁都能配
Jake: These strokes can match with anyone.
Jake: 笔画这个跟谁都能配
Tasha: 这个我们两个的智商
Tasha: This is our combined IQ.
Tasha: 这个呵呵
Shure:  不看那什么可以吗
Shure: Can we not look at that?
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天才
Tasha: I told you I'm a puzzle angel.
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天使
Alice: 我这个在亮吗
Alice: Is mine lighting up?
Alice: 为什么感觉这是粉色的
Alice: Why does this look pink?
Jake: 在亮在亮在亮在亮
Jake: It's lighting up, lighting up, lighting up.
Shure: 在亮在亮
Jake: 是红色的你是电量太少了
Jake: 我看一下你的电在充看一下这个
Jake: 这个在录正在充跟你没关系
Jake: 下面还有一条
Shure: what
Tasha: 这样子的
Jake:这啥呀
Tasha: 看来不是
Jake: 哪个距离不对吗
Jake: Is the distance wrong?
Katrina:  确实该弄长一点
Katrina: It should be a bit longer.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: 中间这个中间这个是谁
Jake: It should be in the middle, in the middle.
Jake: 应该这个中间这个中间
Jake: 这个有点别扭的感觉
Jake: This feels a bit awkward.
Shure:  这个有点别扭的感觉
Jake: 这个大概是这个哎
Jake: This is probably... hey.
Jake: 他是有斜度吗
Jake: Is it slanted?
Alice:感觉不是这个形状
Jake: 但不是他是直的呀
Jake: But no, it's straight.
Jake: 他是直的呀
Jake: 但我觉得
Jake: But I think...
Alice:但我觉得他俩好像可以
Tasha: 他俩好像是一起的
Tasha: They seem to be together.
Jake: 可能原本不是挨着这个屁股对
Jake: Maybe originally it wasn't close to this end.
Tasha: 可能原本不是挨着这个屁股
Katrina:  他这个长度放到紧一些
Katrina: This should be tighter for the length.
Tasha: 因为他们俩感觉缝更紧一些
Jake: 他这个他这个得弄长一点吗
Jake: Should it be a bit longer?
Katrina:  他是可以调节长度的
Katrina: Yes, it can be adjusted for length.
Katrina:  可以他是可以调节长度的对
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If that's the case...
Lucia: 哎不对不对不对不是这个得
Lucia: No, no, no, that's not right, it should be...
Alice: 可能他不在这这只是是大概的
Jake: Maybe it's not here, this is just approximate.
Jake: 可能他不在这这样是大概的
Jake: 然后这个
Jake: And then this...
Lucia: 如果真的在一块的话
Lucia: If it's really on a platform...
Lucia: 如果真的在一个台之后
Lucia: 可能就变成这样了
Lucia: It might become like this.
Lucia: 但是我找不到了
Lucia: But I can't find it.
Tasha: 中间这个如果没有的话就不是
Tasha: If it's not here in the middle, then it's not right.
Tasha: 从中间这个如果没有的话就不是对
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 嗯好难呀
Tasha: Hmm, it's so hard.
Tasha: 嗯好难呀
Alice: 确实
Alice: Indeed, we should use a ruler next time.
Alice: 确实哎以后咱用尺
Tasha: 也不知道谁和谁对
Shure: No idea who matches with whom.
Shure:  也不知道谁和谁对
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩对
Tasha: Is it these two or not like this?
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩不这样
Shure:  嗯我们先把一一边固定上就好了
Shure: Hmm, let's fix one side first.
Shure:  让他不乱窜
Shure: So it doesn't move around.
Jake: 固定一个吧
Jake: Fix one.
Jake: 嗯或者应该倒倒下来得了倒下来
Jake: Hmm, or we should just flip it over, flip it over.
Lucia: 有点难搞
Lucia: It's a bit tricky.
Jake: 你们拼完了
Jake: Did you guys finish listening?
Jake: 你们听完了没有
Lucia: 没有
Jake: 先休息一会是吧
Jake: Let's take a break, right?
Shure: 拼困了
Jake: Yeah, listening made us sleepy.
Jake: 对听困了
Lucia: 所以看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Shure:  决定看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Shure: Decided to see if there's anything else I can help with.
Jake: 我们房间要不要
Jake: Should we...
Jake: 我可能要装饰一下
Jake: Maybe I need to decorate a bit.
Jake: 要不我们踩个风
Jake: How about we go check it out?
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia: 我们是只只把一楼这个客厅装饰一下
Lucia: Are we just decorating the living room on the first floor?